essentially the toad medicine was a five
Meo DMT isn't the only substance out
there which affects our consciousness
and I'm not saying that people have to
take these substances what I'm
recognizing from my own journey is that
nature is psychedelic nature is sacred
yes and we are so disconnected that we
think of ourselves as separate from
nature that we think we are taking
ayahuasca and we are but we're not
separate from the planet which creates
Iowa yeah and so people say like
left-hand path right-hand path these
things are not good it's like we have a
planetary emergency that we are largely
responsible for you know egoic you know
function yeah and time is pretty short
right yeah and so you can get to these
spaces of non-dual consciousness and of
lowering the ego by meditation by other
practices by breath work by Tantra by
meditation and these are wonderful all
paths lead to central source and the
emergency contains within it the
emergence and that's what I believe is
happening on the planet at the moment
okay so all these paths of different
meditation different psychoactive
chemicals these all kind of drive us to
what what you called the source and then
from there what are within this limited
time that we have of trying to you this
emergence that we can come with to solve
the emergencies that are occurring on
the planet looks like Einstein says the
the the problem that the consciousness
which caused the problems is not going
to be the consciousness which solves
them ah and so if we understand what
we've said in this conversation about
history being you know the the canvas of
our trauma essentially and that if we're
trying to save the world from a place of
egoic consciousness we're going to be
trying to solve a million little
problems but all of those problems are
actually a product of our consciousness
if we can come back to our Center
individually and collectively and come
back to feeling and come back to the
heart and come back to compassion and
come back home to where we know we are
that source consciousness within then
that emanation coming out of us will
solve everything
because this is my other short hair say
we're not saving the world the world is
saving itself through us through us by
re-engaging the relationship with us cuz
that's the only problem is that we're
disconnected so tapping into whether you
do meditation or Tantra or I don't know
any you know whatever method gets you in
touch with yourself that is what is
needed at this time because this what is
what is inside us majority of people
have forgotten so in the five Meo
experience which again the the toad for
instance acts as a catalyst it is smoked
so it bypasses the gut it is absorbed
through the blood-brain barrier
incredibly quickly within seconds
because the brain knows what to do with
it because we produce our own five Meo
DMT right essentially you're saying
before what does it do scientifically
like the default mode Network but a
little bit different it lowers the
frontal lobes of the brain
it increases coherence to the point of
hyper coherence of all the network
activity of the brain
so you everything comes online and the
ego drops out of the picture right and
we don't want to kill the ego we need
the ego but the ego needs to know it's
not in control it's not always needed
when the mind lets go
we lower the defenses and in indigenous
understanding they say we have an
energetic body an emotional body in a
physical body and as we go through life
humans store their stresses and traumas
it stores in the energetic body it comes
into the emotional body heart aches and
woes and all that stuff and that those
nexus points with the physical body
that's where sicknesses often develop
and so when we let the ego in the mind
down all of that stuff can come up and
come out for healing with a good
practitioner to help hold space for you
in a ceremony and our natural innate
capability like a newborn baby I call it
you know five Meo is like I call it
God's factory reset it's like a complete
refresh potentially that then aligns you
with your inner self and that you
receive the signal I'll call it a
Galacta Batian right so the frontal
lobes go down the mind goes down the
best Maps I've seen for this of the
Vedic maps of Samadhi their sense of
liberation or one that's that sense of
non-dual unity consciousness in the
Vedic Maps they say that what we think
of is the mind
the ego is like wind on water like
ripples ripples busy busy always
thinking even when you're falling asleep
still thinking we're never free of it
right and so when that lowers we can go
deeper into the ocean of the mind itself
what the Vedic maps called sattva the
depth of that the ocean of mind itself
and we can reach Atman or our true
nature so the mind goes down the heart
and the the stomach instinct those
networks because they're networks as
well they open up they connect to
everything in the unity field and they
feel the signal and that feeling is like
the heart of a star it's like you know
the poet Rumi said the drop rejoins the
ocean we're now individual nature of
holding on and thinking where this low
isn't just surrenders and let's go it
opens up this capacity within ourselves
for the drop - remember the ocean and
that is within us it's like Buddha
nature within us this is what all the
eastern mystic texts have been saying
and it is now firmly within our grasp to
access very rapidly with the power of
five Meo and with the wisdom and respect
and sacredness to do it right so I'm not
suggesting people rush out there and
look for five anymore
you have five Meo in your very nature
you could very well just meditate and
find that ideally an entheogenic
experience like five mio DMT to activate
the the person's full bio electrical
field married with a meditation practice
and a grounding sort of environment to
maintain that vibration because people
find once they've had the five mio
experience it doesn't necessarily go
away this isn't a tab of acid you taken
it wears off eight hours later this is
your deeper being being revealed and
then when the mind comes back online and
it does the mines there but anytime you
learn to lower the mind and the defenses
that vibration is still active within
you right and it's like as more and more
people come online and have their
activations through whatever method
through breath work or Tantra or five
Meo it's like more and more people are
connecting and i call it a samadhi mesh
network the signal gets stronger the
more people will have this experience
however they get there it's almost as if
in the season of consciousness we're in
where we're receiving 5 bar signal like
things are getting really interesting on
earth so the emergency we're seeing is a
direct player form of our egoic
constructor over time coming to a
crescendo and it's not looking good
right don't attach to the outside form
come back to the feeling come back to
the heart come back to the compassion
come back to your true nature
it's perfect everything is perfectly
orchestrated because everything is
incredibly interconnected we are within
the matrix of Pachamama of Gaia she is
in the matrix of the solar system within
the galaxy within the universe all of
space-time within the container of
source consciousness which creates the
universal being somehow through its
mysterious nature and it's somehow
outside and within I never used to be
but I do consider myself a mystic
because there's no other language I can
have to describe this
I'm not even necessarily drawing on the
maps of old I've come across them but if
and when you have this experience it
reveals itself to you in in ways that
are beyond words and beyond language in
feeling in a knowing which just
downloads in his